the me2 movement has hit every aspect of
American society government finance law
the media and entertainment just this
week famed tenor plácido Domingo was
forced to step away from a scheduled
appearance at New York's Metropolitan
Opera after allegations by a number of
women of sexual harassment he strongly
denies the allegations adding I'm
concerned about a climate in which
people are condemned without due process
and you're about to meet two lawyers
women who agree saying the me2 movement
has gone too far
sometimes they say creating a mob
mentality especially on college campuses
the football team the Penguins are the
pride of Youngstown University big Malik
Richmond is senior but there was outrage
when word spreads that a star of the
football team's number 12
Malik Richmond had been convicted of
rape as a juvenile several years earlier
two high school football stars accused
of sexual assault was exploding on the
Internet and dividing people in
Steubenville Ohio the trial received
national attention Richmond and another
member of his high school football team
in Steubenville Ohio were found guilty
of raping a teenaged girl during a
drunken party with the evidence
including a damning videotape of other
students boasting of what happened but
after serving a year in prison
Richmond enrolled at Youngstown
University and the coach had no problem
adding him to the football team I think
he turned that over not only what he did
with us but what he what he did dirt
over the last four or five years but
thousands of students signed petitions
to remove Richmond from the team far
greater numbers than those who supported
him there also is another petition out
seeing a
second chance for Malik that is only at
a hundred and nineteen signatures and
that other signature petition is at
seven thousand signatures the school
gave in kicking Richmond off the team so
he fought back hiring two lawyers from
Cleveland to go to court and defend him
from what they called a mob mentality I
think that was a case that really
highlighted the danger and the
challenges attendant to mob mentality
Christina Zoopla and Susan stone have
taken on what is for many a very
unpopular set of clients where first and
foremost two females in a me-too world
representing mostly males accused of sex
issues and they won in court in
Youngstown arguing the school was wrong
to apply federal law called title nine
which they said did not cover a case
that occurred before a student was at
the University he was a good student
there were absolutely no conduct
violations this young student is a
wonderful human being who's really
learned from his experience and did not
deserve to be punished twice but it took
going to court going to court and now
that's what they're doing around the
country fighting back against schools
they say often don't know what they're
doing as they try to deal with
allegations of sexual abuse and assault
they become many courts Brian and I mean
we have called a lot of them kangaroo
courts because let's be fair these are
people who make up college body the
faculty the administration even the IT
person can take part in the
investigation and the adjudication of
the process for example they took the
College of Charleston to court to defend
a student who had been cleared by law
enforcement but will still be
investigated of sexual assault by the
college authorities I think no school
wants to be viewed as not taking sexual
assault seriously and so colleges and
universities are again wrestling with
this tension between fairness but also
taking a strong position
to address what is a scourge the issue
was highlighted during the Supreme Court
confirmation hearings for Brett
Kavanaugh accused of sexual assault when
he was an undergrad at Yale allegations
he strongly denied well if the same
thing happened today at Yale Yale
probably would issue an investigation
commenced an investigation into justice
Cavanaugh and he would be facing not
only just an investigation but a
suspension or potential expulsion from
school or worse schools issue no contact
orders an investigation unfolds it's not
unusual at all for students who have
been accused before an investigation has
even begun to be asked to move out of a
dorm to have their class schedule
juggled and in reorganized to avoid
running into an accuser at a certain
point on campus so just as Cavanaugh's
life would essentially be ruined even
before an investigation would be
commenced yet the issue of sex assaults
on campuses including rape is clearly a
scourge that has not been addressed
fully one recent survey found that one
in five female students in their fourth
year of college had experienced
attempted or completed sexual assault
while in college and while 65% of
surveyed rape victims reported what
happened to their friends or family less
than 10 percent reported it to police or
school officials but these two lawyers
say the pendulum has now swing too far
with a lack of fairness and due process
and a number of unintended consequences
we've wrestled with students calling our
saying that they're so depressed and
again that comes back to that approach
of treating our students with compassion
and care you've had clients who are
suicidal yes absolutely many because
because they've lost their friends
they're kicked out of their fraternity
they're kicked out of their sports teams
nobody wants to talk to them nobody
wants to study with them and they feel
such shame after the allegation and such
loneliness and such despair that they
can't see
yonder better future a title nine
finding on a student's record is really
the modern-day scarlet letter to get a
different perspective on this I talked
this week with one of the lawyers who's
been a leader in helping women stand up
to men who they say have abused them
Jeannie Harrison has her own former Los
Angeles and I asked her if she thought
me too had gone too far if there was in
fact a mob mentality I don't see that at
all in fact in my practice I find that
it is exceptionally difficult for
victims to come forward and report they
are terrified about the consequences and
many of them even when I meet with them
and offer a tremendous amount of support
which is a core function of my office is
offering that support to victims and
survivors they even still decide that
they're not going to come forward and
report there are many people who don't
come forward ever report because it's
just too scary so I don't think it's a
mob mentality I don't think there's
anything that has gone too far
victims have always been accused of
making accusations or reporting
incidents that the defendant or the
accused say never happened it's it's the
same song a little bit of a different
tune can both be true though can there
be cases where men are essentially what
they say railroaded or falsely accused I
mean there are people who make false
claims but that's part of the system
that's the system is set up to handle
that to test the claims and for victims
to have to testify and put up evidence
which includes their testimony about
what happened and the system is
configured so that they're gonna be
credibility determinations that are made
by the Trier of fact whether that is in
you know school sex abuse cases or
office and work sexual harassment cases
that's the purpose of the system so when
these two lawyers who represent
primarily men on campuses say they have
sympathy for these men they are
ostracized often some of them they say
have actually been suicidal because of
the allegations is there a problem with
the process on college campuses no I
don't think there's a problem with the
press
on college campuses I think that what
does happen there are some cases
obviously on an individualized basis
that seemed not to be warranted we're
certain you know alleged conduct doesn't
seem to have occurred and there is no
doubt that those who are accused of
conduct in which they did not engage
suffer as a result but there are many
people who actually have engaged in
really inappropriate conduct including
sexual abuse and take things way too far
and really you know inflict tremendous
tremendous emotional suffering on women
and men whom they attack and their lives
are changed forever and so I I think
it's regrettable when people choose to
make false accusations but I think that
we cannot allow the backlash which was
almost instantaneous when the me to
movement began we cannot allow the
backlash to drive further drive away the
victims who really do need to come
forward and report these incidents
Jeannie Harrison thank you so much for
joining us appreciate your insights
thank you so much